how important do you think it is for an
actor to know who they are you talked
about turning 40 and feeling like you
know who you are you feel comfortable do
you think people 40 50 60 all of them
know that no no well I think we're
always learning and the moment we say we
know who we are and I can probably come
tomorrow I'll be like I have no idea who
I am I have no idea
what's going on what is happening again
I think having a healthy perspective
having good family you know we're
friends definitely help keep you
grounded having a dog it keeps agree you
know you need things to keep you
grounded and in this industry I think
you need to know what works for you you
need to know what your wheelhouse is you
know again when I first got down here I
was shooting after after meeting man
roles and I'm gonna be the leading man
and I would get close but then they
wouldn't cast me because I'm not what
they were looking for physically I can
give them what they were looking for an
energy wise but not physically so you
know it took me a while to be okay with
being the geek in these particular roles
or or being a this guy and and and then
realizing you know I'm in a good spot
being at being where I'm at because I
can go a million different ways I feel
like you know I'm not I'm not
pigeon holed into one particular
character so I mean it's interesting
that you see yourself as as a geek maybe
you don't I don't see you as that I see
you more as a leading man and I'm sure
there's a lot of women and probably men
too that would do you ever feel pressure
and I think I asked you this earlier but
just to be sort of this this guy that's
people look up to and that they find
attractive I hadn't put anyone know no
but but do you feel that pressure
because if you if someone doesn't see
themselves that way but the outside
world maybe does maybe one casting
director here didn't or this person
didn't but right maybe other people do
do you ever feel isn't it a weird sort
of a thing because other people see you
maybe in a different light right
are more dying man I appreciate that
thank you I again I feel like I didn't
write know it it's okay I again I feel
like I grew into myself you know when I
first got here I looked like I was 12
now is 19 and and I did fit into more of
the geek and there's nothing wrong I am
a geek at heart I you know I'm a serious
geek at heart and maybe that's why I
play so many cuz I just I you know I am
a geek at heart but yes there you know
there's a lot of pressure in this town
and you know for four years
you know this industry makes you very
aware of how you look and and and you
know how you perceived and for a while I
was very self-conscious about my chin
and for years I was always very
self-conscious about it and I could
never figure out why and I would do a
profile shot and I'd be like oh my god I
was so self-conscious about this even as
a young boy and then I got to LA and and
it was sort of you know after going out
and I was sort of in the pinnacle of
like trying to find who I was and and it
was sort of suggested to me that well I
remember asking somebody in this
business well why why am I not getting
these roles and they were like this and
it was like it was so detrimental to me
I was like no it's true like it's true
they okay it's true like it is my chin
you know and it was something that just
bothered me for years
it just it just bothered me and then I
stuff it right and I was gonna I was
gonna get a a chin enhancement I was
gonna get a surgery at the time and this
was like back in the days of Maslin so
it was back in 97 98 99 and so I had
gone and gotten a loan and I was I saw
this doctor here in Los Angeles and okay
I was gonna do it I was gonna get a chin
implant and here we go I was gonna be
taken seriously and then
my friends at the time talked me out of
it and I'm glad I did and it was
something I really at that time found
out who I was without the chain without
anything and I really came into my own
and felt like okay I Know Who I am and
then over time I stuffed still stuff
that insecurity down deep down until it
sort of came out one night when we're
playing a board game with my family
something questioned about the looks and
I said something about my chain and I
was really defensive about it and then
my fam was like why don't you just do it
and I'm like yeah well maybe it's okay
maybe it's okay if I you know this is
something I feel like I need to do
within myself so fast forward however
many years ago I forget me this was like
six seven years ago I went home to a
family doctor and I got a chin implant
and no one would be able to to tell they
just put like a little sort of slit here
and they just kind of slid this little
implant here and then when it was done I
felt like oh okay this is how I felt
inside the whole time but my outer never
really fit this way and then I got the
the chin implant I got the surgery done
and it's actually in the my big big
break documentary and from that day
forth from that day on I've never
questioned it I've never been like oh I
got a chin it just felt like okay now my
face feels like it always should have
and it gave me a confidence inside of
myself that wasn't there before and and
and so and I and I say this because a
lot of actors in this town do things to
themselves to alter their looks in a
certain way and that's something that's
a reality of this business and more
often than not most people have had
something done and I talk about it and
I'm very honest about it and it's in a
movie my big break where they actually
show the doctor doing the surgery on me
and me waking up and so many people lie
about it and it's their own thing it's
it's their own
if you don't want to tell people it's
okay but I wanted to tell people because
it is a it's a thing in this industry
and I say whatever makes you feel better
if it makes you feel better and it helps
you know your confidence then go for it
you know I'm saying and then there are
some people that maybe take it to the
hilt and just do way too much because
they're trying to feed an insecurity
that cannot fill you know what I mean
you have to go within but this was one
thing that made me feel like me so yeah
I think there is a pressure absolutely
and it's how you deal with it
and it's how you find yourself and but
at the end of the day you have to do
something for you and that's why I did
it was for me it wasn't it wasn't for
this industry it was not her acting I
had gotten past that it wasn't it wasn't
for anybody in this town it was for me
and once I did it I felt great and I
haven't really thought about it since so
after the surgery did people treat you
differently no no which is good which is
good they didn't treat me differently I
may be treated myself differently I'm
probably I'm not as um you know if I I'm
not as self-conscious about my profile
you know that was something even as a
boy which at a young age you really
shouldn't have any sort of like
perception of your body and being secure
like that but I was I remember being
very insecure about my profile and then
when it was brought to my attention here
in town I'm like oh god it's it's true
it's all very true but after doing it I
felt so much better and I felt more
confident and myself and no one treated
me differently you know and and and not
many people know you know unless they've
seen the movie they've liked life I
couldn't even tell I'm like well yeah
that was the whole point you know and I
have a really had a really good doctor
who wanted to make it so subtle that it
wasn't a thing you know and then you
wake up you have that moment like oh my
god I look different you know you had to
go through that whole thing and then you
sort of settle into your new look so to
speak but I had before and after
pictures and
made a huge difference and sort of I
think you know maybe it'll make it that
the difference later on about playing a
leading man sort of a role and I'm never
gonna be this sort of leading man that
is the great thing these days it's
leading man has sort of changed into
this it's not you know the typical where
they could looking guy now he could be
more interesting people which i think is
what people want to see it's more
interesting people people that they can
relate to but maybe this makes a
difference maybe it doesn't but for me
it made a huge difference so it sounds
like it was more internal than it was
really where it it made the difference
yeah it was it was very much internal
and it was something that I had I had
stuffed down and it would create such an
anger inside of me until I heard that it
was okay it was always okay my parents
and the family always supported it but
once they said hey just do it I was like
maybe I should maybe I should talk to
Tony and it was a bit about it and they
supported it so you know yeah again it's
it's it's unfortunately the looks
department is a bottomless pit here in
Los Angeles and I think if you could
sort of keep a middle ground don't go
too crazy you know keep who you are but
just maybe you know do the things that
you got to do to make yourself feel
better if some people have trouble
taking compliments and then some people
they can't take enough compliments about
them they're busy giving their own
compliments about right how has that
been for you to come into your own
whatever it is you peace that you've
come to be with yourself how is that to
accept compliments because I'm sure
there's people let's not talk about the
trolls because they always exist right
but but people that do give you genuine
compliments whether it's about your
looks your performance your
ghost-hunting
right right right I you know I take I
think compliments I don't know I
again like there are people that just
want to hear themselves being a door
left and right and I think they got a
real issue I think they got a problem
and I think that's a scary place to be
in you know I think I think if that's
the case you are so insecure and you
need to find something inside of you
that's real because I you know on the
flip side I think I think it's hard to
take compliment sometimes I you know I
guess it falls back into loving yourself
and being okay with taking compliments
and and again I'm always so humbled by
compliments and I take it to heart
because it means a lot to me and these
are people that again in my lives and
these and friends like fans whatever you
know I just I feel very lucky to get
those compliments so I take them very
seriously and into heart
you